foreign
[Music]
it's your boy you know I'm like a rapper
and I say it's your boy got completely
gatted up so far
it's crazy how many
yet twos I got but also dude we're gonna
get into this episode and uh it's gonna
be amazing love you guys uh and honestly
welcome to the next
welcome to this episode of
congratulations
[Music]
so it's like this dude
um I I I I I I love you you know I'm
gonna be in New York coming up here on
Saturday February 18th the second show
there's still tickets left
[Music]
in Kansas City uh Minneapolis
uh Austin Texas Austin Texas we got a
bunch here crystalia.com for tickets go
to chrislea.com and uh it's episode what
is it 300 is this 300 is this 300
episode 300
that's annoy that's very annoying but
it's episode 300 of congratulations yeah
I never thought we'd get it but we got
it dude we got it and we're sitting nice
what did I do to celebrate
um [__] man I was gonna maybe do
something special for the episode 300
but I totally freaking forgot about it
um
and it's okay I totally forgot about it
it's okay because honestly every episode
is the same as me talking about the
hard-hitting issues like pants and
shirts and you know
and whatever's been going down in my
life you know and uh also I do I do talk
about other things too you know I talk
about like we're gonna talk about the
Super Bowl we're going to talk about all
sorts of stuff
Valentine's Day or how when your girls
are single and they do it they do
galentine's day
um which is by the way uh that's I don't
any holiday first of all is made up so
don't make it up your own way right they
did it done Valentine's Day that's it
galentine's day no Thanksgiving that's
it friendsgiving no
just Thanksgiving with your friends you
can be a loser and you don't have to
coin your own term you can be a single
loser and you don't have to go in your
own term
galentine's day no the only thing I
accept is dudes in times day because
single dudes hanging out together on
Valentine's Day that are straight
unbelievable straight dudes in times day
that's the main thing I want to do
straight dudes and times day but um and
yeah so we don't do friends giving and
anytime someone does a potluck you know
potlucks are okay but
basically have a family and if you don't
it's sad and that's fine but Revel in it
just Revel in it be sad feel your
feelings right because if you don't feel
your feelings and you just you know
you're you're going and doing your
friends giving and galentine's day
you're really faking the funk and we
don't want to fake the funk right you
want to feel your feelings
so uh so that's what's up had a great
time on the road where was I uh uh where
was I last even San Antonio did I do
that did I talk about that yet and uh
Houston did I talk about that yet
did it talk about that yet did I talk
about Houston when was I there where was
I last wow no idea yes dude I need
Ginkgo baloga below I need to stop
taking Gabapentin dude I have no I
legitimately have no idea where I was
last wow
San Antonio
Houston
and let's see wait far what was I okay
hold on wait so I think that was the
last one San Antonio
yes
oh
San Antonio
absolutely Bonkers that crowd was
absolutely bunker San Antonio was great
we love it
Houston well it was Sugarland that's why
very rich area of Houston like 19 miles
away from Houston
I tried to pretend like it was Houston
so the people from Houston will go get
it yeah there were over 2 000 people
there
the crowd was okay don't know what it
was but it was only okay had a bad set
felt lonely afterwards yes dude family
wasn't with me felt lonely afterwards
Yes Man didn't want to feel my feelings
wanted to go into my phone hey yes did I
no David Sullivan was there talked it
out with him yes
need to talk out your feelings with
people otherwise you you know you get
you you know it all gets bunched up and
you get [__] up and yes that becomes a
tumor and can't say yes but diet cancer
anyway and it's okay
right because you're going to die cancer
anyway uh uh you know because it's like
if the stress doesn't get you the ice
cream will if the ice cream doesn't get
you
who knows the radiation if there's
something going on you're going to be
living your nuclear power plant or
whatever
um
so
San Antonio Houston and then um what do
you call it
um I went to uh what was the third one
oh Louisiana oh the show was Bonkers
dude the show was bonkers
honestly New Orleans I was like I don't
know about this place it seems like such
a party town that I don't know if
it's going to be a good show or not
because everyone's all interested in
just showing their tits and building out
beads
uh but I did the show and it was great
it's a tough sell in New Orleans for
comedians unless you're Theo Von because
he's from there but it's a tough sell
and the crowd was just awesome I think
the goal I think the trick is to do the
Sunday shows there because their part
their Vibe is party no matter what but
if you do Friday Saturday the vibe is
party and they're not the last thing
you're doing they're doing that night
they're the they're the they're the
they're not the last thing that they're
doing that night but you might be if
it's Sunday we did a seven o'clock show
and maybe at nine o'clock after the show
they're like yeah it's Sunday we're
going home they're not they're not
pre-lit at your show they're late at
your show they're not pre-lit to get to
the lit [__] because nobody is more
activated and excited than a pre-lit
person you want the already you want the
people at your event already lit you
don't want them pre-lit because pre-lit
means everything's gonna be [__]
annoying and shit's gonna catch on fire
and there's gonna be people yelling out
like woo or whatever the [__] it is
especially at a comedy show right
um so we did it uh and it was great and
the New Orleans show was absolutely
fantastic I love those people in New
Orleans and people actually in New
Orleans came out to the show I had no
idea stayed at the [__] I don't know
where we stayed a really nice hotel
right on this on the on the Strip there
and David Sullivan was was was uh always
being like you know David sullerman my
friend came with me for my friend from
Texas and he was always just saying
stuff like is this the French quarter
and I'm just like dude stop asking that
because it doesn't matter where you are
as long as you look up and you're having
a good time and that's a quote to put in
my [__] Tombstone and I'm being dead
serious it doesn't matter where you are
just look up if you're having a good
time breathe easy my baby
that's what we say life rips
speaking of which we got the new merch
going on my life rips we've got the nice
winter colors it's super super nice get
one get one for you get one for your
significant other and cuddle near the
fireplace because that's what it is lots
of storms everywhere the merch didn't
even make it to San Antonio well then a
little bit of it made it to San Antonio
and it didn't make it to Houston and it
didn't make it to Louisiana yes dude
because of the storms all good man and I
tell you that's really [__] annoying
that that happened
because uh that's money from my pocket
that I don't get to have all right it's
all good though dude
but it's like no it's annoying right no
dents but it's annoying though right and
then people complain because dude you
can only get the merch exclusively at
the shows and if you're in Louisiana
waiting for the exclusive merch and then
you can't get it I'm just like okay it
hurts me it hurts you so we're hurt
together in the same boat and it's fine
but dude
you know it is what it is what can I do
what can I do I can't do anything if
there's gonna be a storm coming
um but yay is ridiculously at he's
ridiculously added up like now I'm
actually a tied it up guy
you know how many tattoos I have nine
nine
I got a flower here an elevator a
[__] staircase all all different ways
to get up and down a building and then
[__] uh fire in a an eagle in a plane
and a [__] 40 with the floral
arrangement and then a [__] paper
airplane right here oh dude do not make
me get a cityscape on my neck because I
will
right because I will
because I'm gonna be [__]
ridiculously yet here's um I don't know
man you know I don't know why you listen
to this [__] podcast because
basically
it's ramblings of a Madman but
I love tattoos and when I hit 40 I was
like you know what [__] it I'm going all
in and I did and then I saw you Machine
Gun Kelly and I was like that guy looks
cool with a bunch of tattoos so I'm like
you know what I'm just going for it [__]
it
uh um
also when I hold the [__] microphone
and I do it like this people are just
gonna be like he's at it I'm practically
Lenny Kravitz up in this [__] but I
don't even know if he has tattoos also
when black guys get tattoos like it's
like they need to get you know those
neon ones that they make now those are
[__] pretty cool not my style but
black dudes should get that because when
you just get Black Ink on a brown body
you can't really see it it still does
look kind of cool
but it's kind of like when you're a
white guy and you get tattoos you really
are making a [__] statement you know
what I'm saying
um
so yeah so uh I you know sorry about the
merch [__] but we're we do uh
we do have a we do have a we do have a
good time on the road
love my openers man uh I love the
comedians I shouldn't even say they're
openers that's something I used to say I
wish I didn't do that I'm fortunate to
have comedians open for me that are
already Comedians and very good like
when michelinocchio would open for me
and he still does sometimes but now I
got Denny love and I got Lulu Gonzalez
and uh I'm very fortunate because they
don't need to be opening their stars in
their own right you know Mike Denny and
Lulu but um
but yeah
it's uh yeah so what did you do for
Valentine's Day
did you do the thing where you took your
uh your woman out your wife or your
fiance or girlfriend or whatever it is
did you take them out on Valentine's Day
or did you [__] out and do it like on a
Wednesday or a Monday not the Tuesday
right dude I tell you what
I'm when it comes to Valentine's Day
first of all I made up holiday all
holidays are made up okay it's okay it's
fine right like even Christmas you could
be like well but that's when the Lord
did whatever he did but you're like also
yeah yeah but also you know what I mean
like Babyface has a Christmas album so
really does it
right yeah okay the Lord did this and
great but then there's like jingle all
the way and elves and [__] so it's like
yeah it's kind of made up though right
Santa
yeah but on Easter but that was when the
Lord did whatever he did on Easter but
then also it's like there's a bunny
hopping around okay and you need to hide
a candy and eggs and look so it's like
all right but it's real but also it's
made up so it's real but also is it
like I get you can be religious but also
bunny a bunny right
so uh what'd you do for Valentine's Day
because I'll tell you what I did I
[__] when it comes to Valentine's Day
dude a Mr [__] out
because mostly though because she said
that we could do it on Wednesday and
then mostly also because I have one of
my group my group my men's groups on
Tuesday night and I can't miss it
because I can't miss a man because I
gotta talk about my feelings because I
don't talk about my feelings they'd all
get jumbled and I live in resentment and
when I will live in resentment I get in
trouble
we don't wanna we don't want to live in
resentment right and it's not some sort
of thing where I feel pissed off and
then boom I'm gonna go you know what I
mean just numb out in my phone or numb
out with you know trying to whatever it
is you know thinking about sex whatever
it is numbing out right
instead of what it is is I get
resentment and then it festers and I
live in that world for a while and
before I even know it it's like okay I'm
numbing out
um and that's just a life of an addict
but I will tell you this though dude
we're doing it on Wednesday and mainly
it's it's number one mainly because
uh I gotta do my group but then also my
wife said that we should do it another
day but also that's how you save money
but I didn't even know that it doesn't
even matter right no dents but also
by the time I even tried to do something
on a Tuesday everything was sold out so
all good
do you know what I mean even mozartia so
it's like what can I do dude I live in
L.A and everyone's trying to [__] you
know and I want to get a table but then
it's like can I call and say I'm
kristalia but it's like not really
because John Mayer already has that seed
and who's gonna get it between me and
John Mayer ham and that's okay but it's
like you know
like they gotta be like ah I know you're
crystalia but actually Lloyd Banks is
bringing his side [__] so oh okay
well why is he bringing his side [__]
for Valentine's Day because Wednesday's
the side chick that I didn't know that
my somebody told me that they're like
Monday's the side chick day for
Valentine's Day and Tuesday's the actual
Valentine's Day and I'm like dude is
that actually a real thing and she goes
yeah
and I was like nah but that's like you
saw Sopranos one too many times and
she's like no it's real so Monday night
if you see a dude with a chick that's
their side chick right
that's their side chick but no but I'm
going Wednesday so what I don't even
know what that means but um that's my
this is my whole how about that I'm
bringing my whole life out
side chick Valentine's Day and then the
real [__] on Wednesday I'm bringing my
whole life my whole life out my wife I'm
gonna look in her eyes and eat
some pasta or something
um
so yeah
I don't know man
so don't call it galentine's day that's
where that's that's that's some Kuda
[__]
and then we so you know I don't know is
there love in the air even
is there love in the air
is there Love In The Air Sometimes I
Feel Love in the actual air you know I'm
just like I feel love right like I'm
Walking on Sunshine but then sometimes
I'm like maybe not really there's not
like some love in the air
guess what I don't do anymore
guess what I don't do anymore go to
coffee shops and sit
he graduated dude
I'm 42. I don't go to coffee shops and
sit anymore
maybe when I'm on the road you know me I
hang out at a car shows where I run the
block right not anymore I'm 42. I've
decided that's too old to sit at coffee
shops and hang out anymore
Duty makes decisions he lives with
intent okay
and if you're 42 you shouldn't do it
either how about that dude there's so
many [__] rules in life that are the
real rules
right people are always like yeah don't
Rob and I'm like yeah don't Rob but the
real rules though
so
I don't do it anymore I just go I get
the coffee and I leave
what we gonna do man
what are you gonna do right what are we
gonna do
that's what I decided
there's no reason for me to be in a
coffee shop just sitting around
I'm 42.
and
been thinking about this
uh part of it is you know family man
want to be with my wife and son a little
bit more
and uh and that's that's fine but I was
at a coffee shop the other day
uh it was yesterday
I went in
to just get the coffee and bounce out
because that's what I do now dude right
I'm like I'm really cool about it I'm
like why is it gonna oh he says I
thought oh okay oh but that's the
comedian oh okay I guess he's gone well
I wanted to ask for a paper but okay
whatever
I go in and you know this thing where
like now by the way the whole [__]
remember we used to just put our cards
in the thing and and and then take them
out and now it's first of all you used
to just give the credit card to the guy
and the guy would be like first of all
before that you just use cash
right like in 1950 or something I don't
know when the credit cards come out
2005. and you just give cash
and then the guy would take the cash and
then give you more cash right when do
credit cards come out
1960s all right
so when my dad was born people were just
their bot their pockets just looked like
big [__] water beetles right if you
were Rich because you couldn't even have
or you had checkbook you know you're the
[__] with the checkbook at [__]
Savon whatever but then they invented
the credit cards
and then by the way before money there
was just you would trade [__]
you know you'd be like hey I really like
uh those coffee beans can I get a bag of
them and people would be like yeah but
what do you got and you'd just be like
you want this scarf
and they'd be like it does get cold
around here
you just give them a scarf and you give
you like two bags of beans right
um and then money
which I never really was a big fan of
money because you give people money and
you'll give them like one dollar if
something is 45 cents and then you get
back like two quarters in a nickel or
even worse
you know three dimes
two nickels and
two more nickels and then another nickel
you know and then you just got like so
many I gave you one and now I gotta have
all this [__] right that sucks to
give something
one dollar and then more stuff that's
actually less
I'm not a part of it right
so and heavier right so it's like
money's [__] then credit card's cool
then it's like you give the guy the
credit card the guy takes a credit card
does the thing and then gives it back
and you gotta sign it it's too much then
they came up with the [__] you slide
the credit card thing in great take it
out great fine I got I I do the credit
card [__] now but now it's like
they're like
ah
either slide it or put it in for a
little bit
or just put it around the area
and it's like okay first of all
pick one this is your [__]
establishment I have the card what the
[__] is there to do
everybody's got the [__] tap [__] so
if you just want to make it to tap [__]
tell me to just wave it around the area
now that doesn't this is one of those
things the technology is not caught up
to the thing because a lot of times
they're like yeah the tap function
actually it doesn't really work
so slide it in and you're like ah all
right I'm just getting used to the tap
[__] now but fine
so it's completely [__] annoying
I want to go back to the days where you
just take my credit card do what it is
you need to do now uh people are like oh
yeah but it's safety in Australia
they've been doing it forever and so is
Britain and it's like okay yeah I guess
it's safer if some not everybody's
holding my credit card but whatever dude
here's the [__] annoying part
they there's too many screens now
you tap it they go okay is this amount
okay yes okay you want
tip
uh
all right and then give you like three
or four options for a tip it'll be like
10 20 30 like first of all the balls
right
like 20 okay and I do 30 a lot of the
time but most people ain't [__]
we fly high No Lie we rolling
and like I I get it right but since
since I'm the kind of guy who you know
everybody do they know when I walk in we
fly high No Lie we rolling
they know right so I'm like well I can't
not tip 30 and then somebody tweets out
any doesn't tip well
but also I don't do it to get in right
with [__] Jesus I do it because you
know what this coffee the tip is two
dollars [__] it who cares right
but
I don't here's what I don't like
you look at it now I'm gonna do it with
you as if we're doing like you see the
ten percent and then you see the 20 and
then you see the 30 so everybody knows
the left side is the little tip if
that's what you want to do
sometimes companies are Savvy like
sandwich places like Mom and Pop places
they'll flip it and put the 30 first
then 20 and then 10. so you think
automatically you go Boop and hit the 30
even though you think you're hitting the
ten and then you go ah [__] it and then
sign the thing and hit it right dude
that is some [__] [__] [__] that's
undercover that's like the [__]
GoFundMe how they they add the tip in
already
they say you're going to get 15 right
and you go what what and you got to
unclick it
that's a bit like robbery it's an
unspoken thing so it's not like robbery
but it's an unspoken thing but we all
know that the money's supposed to go
little money to the left and then upper
upper bigger money to the right okay
but here's the deal
there's too many screens right because
then you got to click the tip and then
you gotta sign it and click the okay
it's like dude this is taking longer
than when we just used to trade [__]
it would be way quicker if I just got
two packs of beans and I pulled the
scarf off
so now it's taking too long as it is but
here's the most
here's the thing
sometimes
because thing the screens are different
and by the way thank God you're
listening to this podcast because this
is very important and like And subscribe
honestly
and leave a comment on how do you feel
about this even though I don't care but
I want you to know I want you to do it
it helps outgrow them
um
do I
when When people's when when you get the
the tip screen
and you walk away sometimes you don't
think of you like I hit the thing I
gotta go away now and then they and then
the tip screen is left open right and
the guy behind the thing is like oh [__]
he didn't do the tip screen
never once have I ever heard the guy say
oh man you didn't do the tip screen not
once in my life have I ever heard that
but I have heard
people say oh it's asking you some
questions
now we know what's going on there
they don't want to sound greedy
[Laughter]
and I get why they do it and they don't
want to put you in that uncomfortable
situation where it's like oh [__] yeah I
wasn't gonna give you a tip I was gonna
put zero but I [__] up now you you're
looking at me do it because you know I
didn't do it so
dude today the guy goes like this not
even like he didn't even do it any sort
of I understand you don't want to say oh
you didn't do the tip but he goes like
this it was well across the coffee place
because I forgot to click all the
[__] buttons he says oh man it's
still asking you a question
and I go I say huh and he says it's
still asking you a question and I'm like
oh I walk over and I say yeah yeah and I
give him a 30 tip because you know what
I mean
but it's like
and and you know what I mean but it's
like
dude it was so [__] funny and those
are the things I think about and I'll go
a step further those are the things I
think about
all day long
now
did I do couples therapy three days in a
row and did it last for hours each day
and the answer is yes
did I talk about real feelings and
emotions yes
did my wife talk about real feelings and
okay yes we did
was it hard for me yeah
why
because I want to think and talk
only about things
like the Tipping function at a coffee
shop
why
because I want to talk about things that
interest me and I think are funny but
why
because it's a defense mechanism
so I don't have to deal with real
feelings
why because something happened in your
childhood
[Music]
wall up
what
I'm not telling
[Music]
so it's like
[Laughter]
oh [__]
so I'll just get a bunch of tattoos and
keep on living you know what I mean dude
it's just life rips man it does you're
either growing or dying I say that
you're either growing or dying I fully
believe that you're either growing or
dying because one time Ed OG said death
is just the moment when the dying ends
and as a young lad 25 I just go hmm
that's interesting because I've also
heard the quote
to live is to
Find meaning through the suffering yes I
pulled it out I thought I forgot it dude
and I'm like hmm
but I've also heard Life is a Highway
I'm gonna ride it all night long so I'm
like which one though am I going to be
super jerk off positive or super jerk of
negative right
and I'm like [__] man
what I think is you're either growing or
dying because that's your choice
that's your choice you could either grow
or die and death is just the moment when
the dying ends if you're not growing
it's all about choice
you gotta grow or die
that's why when they say stuff like
skate or die I'm like
no there's so many different things you
can do in between skating and dying like
eating a blueberry muffin taking a walk
around the park
flying to Fiji
but there's nothing you can do in
between growing or dying you're either
doing one or the other so that's why I
say grow or die which one are you doing
I choose growl
but it's hard
right it's hard because you're always to
grow you have to feel your feelings you
can't no matter you can't only think
about things like tipping at coffee
shops and cargo pants
you got to think about
the stuff that
hurts and it's real
grow or die
um so yeah
so that's why I did public therapy for
three days in a row for way too many
hours it's all good
I saw
got so much mucus for some reason yes
all good uh I saw yes dude I saw um
the Super Bowl
or as I call it the stupid ball no I'm
kidding it was actually a really good
game it really was a good game
Patrick Mahoney Pat Maho pat pat Mahoney
Pat Mahoney Pat my homeboy
um and then the other guy Jalen hurts
Everybody Hurts
it's a good song sometime
um
and it was good dude it was a good game
uh and then Rihanna went on the thing
and then of course here's the thing
Rihanna can do no wrong
ever
now I don't mean to take away from her
she is talented as all get out she's got
a great voice and she's beautiful
and she's just cool right
big Rihanna I didn't know she had she
said second in the Super Bowl I'm like
she got that many hits
they kept coming dude
foreign
I'm watching her do the thing and she
can do no wrong like honestly Rihanna
could legitimately have like
she could go rob a bank without a mask
and people be like well she deserves
that money
and people be like it was actually my
money at the bank and they said yeah but
you're not Rihanna
and they go what
what what I mean
but why does she get it she sings Rude
Boy
you're like all right
I guess just kind of shitty it was
she took five thousand dollars for me
and so much from other people like all
throughout it like yeah but
umbrella
all right
also she's one of those women that by
the way she's super sexy but she's one
of those women that everyone talks about
is so beautiful that they just it's like
okay dude
all right right
and she wore all pink in the and she was
good and she was pregnant and that was
amazing because let me tell you
something dude she performed halftime
she does this thing where she's like I'm
Dan she's a great dancer but she didn't
really do it this time because she's
pregnant and she's doing the thing where
she's like I don't give a [__] about the
dancing I'm cool I do whatever I want
and it was very cool how she was doing
it it was great it was a great
performance the only other performance
that I liked in recent history was
um
the where Eminem and all the guys did it
and 50 Cent was like upside down and uh
Adam Levine is cool I didn't really see
the one with the
whatever the [__] it was
um what's their band name
maroon 5.
um I do feel like Rihanna was killing it
and then I'm like okay so she's pregnant
and then I'm like how far along is she I
guess she's having another baby but ASAP
Rocky right that's who it is because she
had to run recently and apparently he
[__] squirted all up in her
immediately after because she's already
pregnant again although I'm no good with
time like if you ask me when the Razor
scooter came out I'd be like I was at
2016 and people were like dude it was
the 80s and I'm like oh
I said well what movie is George
Hamilton coming out in and they're like
huh and I say the gold guy who does the
and they say he's dead he's not but I'm
like oh I didn't know how old he was
okay whatever
like I have no I'm not good with time
so
so uh
she does the dancing and the singing and
her voice is amazing and she's way Sky
High up into the
I mean she's on a plank that's like also
by the way like super if she fell off no
more Rihanna
like like zero like zero more real if
she fell off just no more shine bright
like a diamond shine bright like a
diamond
zero more shining like a diamond more
just being in the dirt really dark
like dead okay so she's on this plank
and it's like wobbly and she's just
sitting there just [__]
you know
shine bright like a die umbrella
just killing it I'm not doing too much
dancing because she's pregnant I thought
in the beginning I was like oh she's not
doing too much dancing because she's on
a plank she can follow up and break all
of her but no the truth is she revealed
the bump but didn't even do a thing like
look at my bump she was just like I have
a bump and I don't give a [__] about
y'all and that's super Rihanna and I
love that
but then I'm like
Rihanna's doing all that [__]
um
and my wife is like
can you get
me a LaCroix
and I'm just like
I've been saying yeah for like seven
months
she's seven she's almost eight months
pregnant my wife and I'm like
she's like hey could you make sure the
heat isn't and I and I get up
and I go do it
and I'm like
one more month left which is like I
gotta be doing all sorts of [__] but I'm
just gonna go like this
when she says hey Chris can you get the
salt or go or the Postmates is here can
you grab it I'm just gonna go like this
Rihanna
hey why don't you shine bright like a
diamond and go downstairs and get it
you know what I'm talking about
I'm joking because I love her and she's
my angel but also on the comedy tip
why don't you saunter down there and and
why don't you do that because this rude
boy is cool right now I'm just chilling
and you're actually right
she said but I'm eight months but I say
but Rihanna
remember how she was really high up in
Super Bowl 57 or whatever it was
and now she could have died
what I'm talking about
oh
dude every dude who had a pregnant lady
with them when they were watching the
Super Bowl and Rihanna did the [__]
[__] and she's up there with seven
months pregnant or however a month
pregnant she was
every dude does every dude like this to
their wife like this
but and she said well I'm not Rihanna
and go but you could get the salt right
okay I'm just saying I know you don't
and she's Rihanna I'm not asking you to
stand up on the plank and
sing
15 hits right which I don't I don't
think you should do even when you're not
pregnant I think I'd be exhausting
I get that's Rihanna
you can't turn the air on
that's all I'm saying dude
I'm having a sympathetic pregnancy
though so
how about when dudes and then and
somebody at the time you know it's a
real thing they say sympathetic
pregnancies and they say oh like the
dude gets tired too because of the
because he nutted in her six months ago
okay cool I'll buy that
then who's getting the [__] Tabasco
I mean I'm talking about
so anyway Rihanna made me question about
that because like people think somebody
told me once that they thought that blue
balls I think it was my wife she said
she thought blue balls was a conspiracy
that guys just do it so they could be
like ah come on I need to I need a
release you know I've never had blue
balls myself right but
um she thought it was conspiracy oh no
no no no that's not what she thought was
a conspiracy she thought it was a
conspiracy that when guys got kicked in
the nuts that it hurt she
when she was younger and I'm like no
dude it hurts so bad
but I think it's a conspiracy with
what's going on with these you know
I saw Rihanna dancing on a plane
what is she four months PR five months
pregnant I started doing it
okay
so all I'm saying is
why are you making me drive down to get
cold cuts when Rihanna's dead of the
plague right I'm not the one with the
fat belly but you know it's like
shine bright like a diamond go down to
Ralphs
we got the [__] [__] going on
um
there's a movie
that I caught
on I was on iTunes or whatever the [__]
they call it now Apple TV what are they
not Apple TV the what's the thing where
you go can rent in the movies it's not
Apple TV whatever it is you know what
I'm talking about movies you just click
on movies for at when you have the Apple
app right and you could just buy or rent
movies right and if sometimes it's like
hey rent this movie for two dollars and
you're like oh cool and then it'll be
like rent this movie for twenty dollars
and you're like what
but both of them have Matt Damon in it
and you're like why and they're like
well because this one isn't available
for purchase yet and you're like none of
this makes any sense but whatever
not a big deal so
I rent I see the thing on the suggested
for you whatever and it's called
skinamarink
so I'm like
I see the visual that's captivating to
me of a little boy upside down on the
ceiling the ceiling is the floor and the
floor is the ceiling and the image is
upside down and it it's grainy and it
says skinamarink
so I'm like
the only thing this could be is a horror
movie right because of the grainy
footage because of how it's weirdly
upside down and then the number one
thing that is always in a horror movie A
little boy so like you can't nowadays
have a horror movie without a little boy
in it you know that right like it just
doesn't happen
it's either the little boy is not in it
the little boy is either the object of
the [__] scariness or the little boy
is the scariness and you don't know
until the end like that stupid movie
Identity with John Cusack
so I go to click the
the trailer because I watch trailers I
need to see if it were my appetite
because I see on Rotten Tomatoes at 71
with the Rotten Tomato and which is a
good thing for Rotten Tomato but also
Rotten Tomato we all know is absolutely
horse yank it's not good Rotten Tomatoes
either or only the haters voting on the
thing or all of the Asians that are
excited about the Asian movies and
that's why xinji or whatever the [__]
that movie got 100 written and I looked
at it and it was the worst Marvel movie
ever
Seven Ten Rings whatever too many rings
right
even Lord of the Rings didn't specify it
and it was just kind of one ring right
but xinji 10 Rings you're just like all
right
that movie was
awful and all the Asians got on there
like oh finally this is the [__]
Asian one boom boom 100 rating dude
Rotten Tomatoes you got no legs to stand
on now after that xinji 99 whatever okay
but it's the dorks that do it you know
or the haters
Spider-Man far from home get the [__]
far from my home I'm not watching that
so
so now I look at the skinamarink 71 raw
Tomatoes now I'm like okay a real rating
a real [__] rating I can get by
something that stuff that's the best
that is the best rating you can get for
Rotten Tomatoes is 71 percent
in my
egotistical opinion
all right
but I look at the preview because I
still want to whip my appetite right I
see the 71 rating but I'm still like but
should I actually watch this
should I pay the three dollars for it of
course doesn't matter but
so click the preview I'll watch the
preview
I don't know what's going on the whole
time I watch it
the whole preview the two minute preview
I don't know what's going on the only
thing I know is that it looks creepy and
these kids like can't really find
anything that they're trying to look for
so I
my um
friend is is over
our friend Kristen and I a friend and
she says
let's watch it
so I say really it's a real specific
watch you sure you want to watch it or
you want to watch something where we can
just like veg out and she says I don't
know it looks cool
so I say all right I turn it on I turn
it on
this movie skin armoring skinamarink
it's so very weird for 10 minutes
it's got It's like basically a slideshow
it's showing pictures some of them are
moving but most of them are not they're
still well they're moving pictures but
of still things it's like they're
filming the side of a wall
somebody's feet
the armrest of a couch
and nothing's really happening there's a
TV that's on in the background of a
cartoon with old-timey music which makes
it creepy and then every now and then
somebody says something but you don't
know who's saying it because it didn't
show any faces yet
and you don't really know what they're
saying because you can't really hear it
because it sounds like this
except for the fact that
sometimes there are subtitles and they
let you know what the person sings so
I'm like okay this is very interesting
and I'm watching it for 10 minutes and
I'm like hmm
but also
come on
what's going on here
make it a little more digestible
is this a movie
or is it ASMR
because the whole movie sounds like this
and while that's happening you'll hear
someone do this
now if you're alone in your car and it's
night time that was probably a little
creepy right
but that's what the movie is and I'm
watching it at night and my our friend
is there and thank God okay
Kristen has already went to bed right
because she's
pregnant and she goes to sleep at like 9
30 now and she's not Rihanna you know
what I'm talking about
so I'm watching this with our friend and
20 minutes goes by
Haven't Seen A Face
still pretty much moving images of still
things sometimes a toy will come into
frame and like skip across the floor
where's boom
and it says where's mom on the thing
and I'm like all right look it is creepy
but but also
come on
make this a little more digestible all
right so I look at our friend and I say
you want to keep watching this or what
and she says I don't know
so I'm getting no help from her I'm
getting no help from the [__] movie
I'm just like stuck it's 30 minutes into
this movie the movie's an hour and a
half and I'm supposed to start googling
I'm like I gotta Google to see if it's
so I Google
why is Skinnamarink so scary
and it comes up and now people I see
people saying
this is the scariest movie of all time
I see people saying I've never seen
anything scarier I see people saying
there are horror movies that's not what
this is this isn't scary this is
terrifying so I'm like what so now I'm
like all right I guess almost I guess
I'm along for the ride but I better
start seeing some faces or something
going on
[Music]
and a picture of like a tricycle and I'm
like all right
okay but I gotta I can't lie
if our friend left
I'm turning something else on
not because I'm bored
because I'm scared
South Park's gotta go on after that
because this looks like the devil filmed
this
there are no shots outside now so now I
notice in the movie all the doors and
the windows gone the house had doors and
windows then they're gone and now the
kids saying
I don't know if we they can't find their
dad where's their dad no clue so now
these kids are just in a room in their
house
watching they don't know where their dad
is they're alone and the TV won't turn
off so I'm like that's a scary nightmare
in a way right it's like a nightmare in
the way of oh hey what was your
nightmare about not like this kind of
nightmare where you're like oh dude I
was at War and all of a sudden I
realized I was fighting werewolves and
the werewolves came and ate me and
you're like oh I get how scary that is
it wasn't a nightmare like that it was
like one of those nightmares where
you're like dude I had this crazy
nightmare last night and somebody's like
what what was it about and you say I was
with like my grandma or someone's
grandma and it was my house but the
doors weren't there and my grandma kept
trying to like make me pasta but she was
in the other room and I wasn't sure if
that's really what she was doing but
then also there was like this pile of
bricks and I somehow had to eat them but
I couldn't cut them up so I had to
swallow them whole and you're like oh
well that's way worse than fighting
werewolves
and how long were you in the Dream well
they say dreams don't last more than
three minutes but I know I was in there
for 11 years oh
well this [__] purgatory
I'd rather have werewolves eat me than
that right so so now I'm watching this
movie I'm like this [__] is
really kind of creepy
I keep watching and
an hour in I [__] you not zero Faces
Sometimes you see these children's feet
you just see the a Lamppost or like a
foot of a bed
then the TV's on the back
and I'm watching for an hour now I'm
like hooked I'm like okay well I gotta
ride this out and I look and they made
the move for fifteen thousand dollars
and opening weekend I made two million
dollars and I'm like what and then I'm
like oh the director
was a YouTube guy who would make short
films about people's nightmares and then
made this movie and now it's like got
some sort of awards and it's really
doing something I'm like oh my God so
then
about an hour into the movie I hear not
just one of the children's voices who
are alone by the way I hear someone say
s
and on the screen it says put the knife
in your eye and I go
huh
well
I'm not sleeping tonight
because then you see the back of a kid
shake a little bit and you don't really
know what he's doing but then after
about a minute or two you realize oh
that kid probably put a knife through
his eye
it shows more toys and [__] and by the
way I'm not gonna ruin the movie
because you know why you can't
if I told you every single thing that
happened in this movie it wouldn't be
ruined in the movie because you can't
ruin the movie you can't spoil it
it's just terrifying the movie ended
and
our friend
left
and then I was sitting there in the
kitchen and I said well I guess I gotta
go to sleep now
because I'm tired went to sleep
next to my wife fell asleep
woke up in the morning
forgot that I saw the movie
then when I remembered I saw the movie
I was
I had this emotional response with me
that was a very low grade kind of what
the [__] did I watch last night it was
all day then the next night my wife went
to bed early and I was downstairs alone
and I was too scared so I had to watch
[__] South Park this movie
skinamarink is
it is one of the creepiest movies I've
ever seen in my life
and I am I really want to know what you
think of it I don't know if it's I guess
it's good because it made me feel very
very weird and it's very very scary for
zero reason okay and of course you know
me addicts Behavior I went on the guy's
YouTube page and I watched a lot of his
short films they're all absolutely
[__] terrifying so what the [__]
going on I have no idea but go see that
movie skin in my rank it's worth three
dollars to rent it
um
it's called skinamarink too you know
skinamarinka Rinky Dink Skinner rink to
do and then he purposely called it
Skinnamarink not Skidamarink because
Skidamarink is that children's song and
they didn't want kids to Google it and
get the wrong thing and then all of a
sudden their what the kids are watching
with the northern Roy
mama what's the knife in the eye
scary [__] bro I love movies like that
because it's like you know it's not just
like you can watch how many times can
you watch [__] wakanda forever
I've watched in the wakanda forever 11
times and I've never seen wakanda
forever it's all the same [__] as my
point
all right let's do a few I know it's uh
a few but we'll do a few um
what do you call it misconnections
we got the thing here
nice look at that
oh wow we also got [__] uh
chat GPT jokes
right here let's do those
chat GPD crystallia jokes this is chat
GPT you put in crystallia and something
I think it's dinner parties here it was
the first one and and I'm gonna do the
bit as I would do the bit but I did not
write this chat jibi did this I have not
read these yet but I'm gonna do them all
right
as in me
Alami
I'm really gonna do them as I do them
like I'm not gonna half-ass it
dinner party so dinner parties dinner
parties are like they're like a game of
Russian roulette with food right you
never let me start over
dinner parties are like you know what
dinner parties are like a game of
Russian roulette with food you never
know what you're gonna get some nights
it's a five-star meal other nights it's
a ball is cereal and then there's always
that one person who brings store-bought
pasta salad like come on man we all know
that's not a homemade
dude that's amazing
wow that's so bad and and I did it right
dude that's exactly how I would do it
all right I'll give you another one this
is jeopardy uh meet Chris Chris's style
of things on uh gen on uh on Jeopardy
um
okay
or Ken Jennings maybe it was because I
don't know what it was Ken Jennings
whatever Ken Jennings on Jeopardy that
guy's like a human encyclopedia man I
mean I Google things and I still I can't
keep up it's like playing a game of
Trivial Pursuit with a history professor
and the worst part is he's got that
poker face you never know if he knows
the answer if he's just bluffing wow so
[__] not funny all right
now crystallia chat GPT they put in
crystallia and iPhones one fire did this
here we go
iPhones man they're like the new
ex-girlfriends they always want more
attention more updates and more money
and every time you think you've got them
figured out they go and release a new
model it's like hey remember that thing
you had yeah it's outdated now but don't
worry you can buy the new one for just a
few hundred bucks more wow that actually
is impressive chat GPT can understand
what a joke is and that is a horrible
joke but also how did they do that
here's one on Apple Chris Dalia and Chad
GPD Apple same thing like an iPhone's
manufacturer here we go Apple man
they're like the cool kids in high
school they've got the latest gadgets
the silica's design and they've always
seemed to be one step ahead but look
let's be real all right they're just
overpriced computers with a fruit logo I
and don't even get me started on their
marketing it's like they're trying to
make a computer seem like a lifestyle
Choice hey buyer computer and YouTube
can sit in a sterile white room and look
cool dude how do they know how I would
do that that's bad a bad version of me
but also how do they know I would do
that also that's probably better than 30
of this podcast but um all good wow we
got to do that every time that's
unbelievable that they did that how did
they do that
she had gbt is amazing
we're done we're [__] let's do a few
uh
things I gotta do another show here
Miss connections here we go
the man who is on top of his job Marina
Del Rey I'm looking for that guy who was
mature has been in the business for a
long time and on top
of his job there's a little nugget spot
in that tunnel that needs to be tested
and prodded and they need him to know
exactly where it is and how it works you
have to go slow or else it won't work
are you him
[Laughter]
dude
you know why exactly I mean we know what
he's talking about anal right but why is
he acting like he's they're looking for
a a nugget of [__]
that's disgusting hey guy
he's looking for excrement
like just be like hey guy come do
plumbing on me
why why so specific that's what why so
specific
that's this is like r b how it gets so
now I'm looking for a guy who's mature
he has the business for a long time
head on top
boy
point of his job there's a little nugget
in a tunnel and he needs to be intestine
Illinois
you have to go slow
or else it won't work
are you him dude the little water drops
in it you know well that's it for
YouTube if you want to catch the rest of
the episode The uncut the unedited the
ad free episode of congratulations all
you got to do is go to patreon.com
crystallia and you can get that and all
the other episodes what we do is we have
one episode extra a month that you
cannot get on YouTube you gotta be on
the patreon that's just six bucks go do
it right now and you get all the backlog
episodes we have so many right now we
could go binge them
you know like it's uh the show 24. and
uh you know that's it thanks guys
[Music]
foreign